[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
demystifying machine learning driving
image analysis using your biological
knowledge
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by leica microsystems to learn more
visit leica-microsystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
quinn tran applications and marketing
manager for avia at leica microsystems
and joining us for our live q a session
hoyan lai content marketing manager and
senior application specialist for avia
at leica microsystems
dr tran you may now begin your
presentation
hello everybody welcome to this webinar
and thank you very much for joining us
here today my name is quinn tran i am
the application and marketing manager
for the avia team here at leica
microsystems
today uh today's webinar will be about
demystifying machine learning
particularly how to use machine learning
to drive your image analysis using your
own biological knowledge
so let's quickly take a look at our
agenda
first i'll be talking to you about how
to leverage machine learning for your
image analysis
we'll then dive into some machine
learning fundamentals
and then i'll share with you some of my
best practices for training a pixel
classifier a machine learning tool that
we commonly use in microscopy image
analysis
we'll then in with a q a session so that
you have time to ask any questions you
would like
so let's dive in
so i like to
think about the ability to use machine
learning and can achieve broad
categories first is image enhancement
for microscopy images
now i have four examples to showcase to
you here but i do want to mention this
is not an exhaustive list of ways you
can use machine learning for your images
it's just the four that i commonly you
commonly see
when i'm working with our customers
so the first example i have for you is
this ability to extract multiple
structures from a single channel so here
on the left hand side in the original
image we have a stain that has stained
the cell
membrane the cell nucleus and so and
also a bit of the cell cytoplasm
and for subsequent analysis what we
really want to do is separate these
three components into three separate
channel so we have the ability to
um
[Music]
tweak and and analyze and optimize the
image analysis protocol for these three
components separately
so using the pixel classifier the
machine learning tool that i just
briefly mentioned we've essentially
taught the software what each of these
three components look like and then have
separated them out so now the someone
membrane is
in its own channel depicted here in the
yellow
the cell nucleus is its own channel
depicted here in the purple and the same
for the cell cytoplasm depicted here in
the red so now when we do the analysis
for these components it's going to be
much easier because they're separated
from one another
my second example here is going from a
heterogeneous staining to a more
homogeneous staining and i think you can
see that
heterogeneous staining best in this
nucleus this large nucleus down here
and basically because of the
heterogeneity of this staining it makes
any image analysis we do that our
intensity base very difficult what's
going to typically happen is that
instead of detecting this as one nucleus
it's going to break this apart into
smaller pieces which is not what we want
to do because that's not represented
representative of the biological um
the biological nucleus here
so using again the pixel classifier what
we've done is essentially even out the
staining so now the entire large nucleus
has a more
consistent uh intensity level of the
staining so that when we do image
analysis it's a lot easier to detect
this as one whole piece
my third example is enhancing certain
objects of interest in your images and
in this particular case i'm showing you
a histology image and what we wanted to
pull out or enhance is these regions and
these cells that have this stain and
again using the pixel classifier we've
done that and that's depicted here in
the yellow so that we're really pulling
this information out and away from the
background of the rest of the image
and then my fourth example is going from
a phase to a fluorescent-like image so
here we taught the pixel classifier to
detect this
neuron
both the soma
and the dendrites here that are
protruding out and create and
essentially creates a fluorescent-like
image of this neuron which allows you
to do any subsequent image analysis at a
much easier level because now you have
an image that is really high
um that has a really high
signal or intensity of the neuron versus
a low
signal for
all of the other background components
now the other broad category i like to
think about when it comes to machine
learning and image analysis is the
ability to go from the original image
all the way to segmentation so my first
example for you here is segmenting cells
in histology images so this would allow
you to do cell counting it would allow
you to do cell counting um in certain
regions of interest things like that are
significantly easier to do now
the other example i have is segmenting
cells in phase contrast image so unlike
the example we talked about just briefly
um where we enhance that neuron we're
now going from
this the
phase contrast image all the way to
segmentation this would make analysis
such as cell counting or um
understanding some confluency
it a lot easier for you in these types
of face contrast images
my third example for you is segmenting
cells in fluorescent images so here we
have the scenario we we spoke about
earlier where the staining of the
nucleus is heterogeneous so it makes
that a little bit tricky to do um using
traditional intensity based threshold
algorithms so with the machine learning
algorithm we're able to kind of pull all
of this together and detect these
nuclear
nuclei in one large piece that is more
representation of their um
of their biology here
the other thing i would i like to point
out is um when it comes to segmenting
images cells and fluorescent images i
also find the pixel class of our
classifier
um to be really helpful in detecting
cells that are
of an irregular shape they don't have
this round globular shape which a lot of
intensity based algorithms are optimized
for because that's the most common way
we see ourselves
but when we have something irregular
those algorithms may not work the best
and i find that moving to a machine
learning
tool allows me to kind of be flexible
and accommodate those irregular shapes
such as cells that are elongated or
cells that have
protrusions that you want to capture
all right now let's talk about some
machine learning fundamentals and i
typically like to start by looking at
the traditional image analysis workflow
and how that compares to an ai based or
a machine learning image analysis
workflow
so in traditional image analysis
workflow we human beings the expert
create the rules um rules such as my
cells have to have an intensity level of
100 above my cells have to be in this
particular size range we take these
rules and the images of the data and put
it into the program and the program
provides us with answers these are your
detected cells
for the machine learning framework we're
essentially flipping that script what
we're going to provide the framework is
examples or answers of what the cells
look like
what the object of interest looks like
feed the answers and the data into that
framework and the framework provides us
with those rules so again those rules
like we just briefly mentioned cell size
cell morphology cell intensity profile
the framework gives us the rules that
make this cell or object of interest
unique
so that because of that flip you might
be asking how does this actually work
what does it usually look like to train
a machine learning algorithm
so this is a video showcasing you how
the pixel classifier a machine learning
tool in avia gets trained
so in avl when we create a pixel
classifier we immediately get two
classes what you want and what the
background and then we provide examples
and this process is actually fairly
simple because providing examples or
answers
is essentially painting pixels that make
up what we want and then pixels that are
considered background for us
so again that providing of the answer
part is actually fairly simple and it's
just a painting method the answers and
the data is now fed into the machine
learning algorithm which spits out the
rules and then the rules are applied to
this image so using that small subset of
um examples we provided we create those
rules and apply it to all of the pixels
in the image and it enhances each of the
pixels it classifies each of those
pixels as what we wanted in the yellow
or background kind of in this gray or
non-existent color that we've shown here
so again we're feeding the answers by
painting those examples in in the data
into the algorithm and getting out the
rules here
so let's take one step further and ask
ourselves and talk about
the algorithm that is behind this tool
which is the random force algorithm
it's a
fairly commonly used machine learning
algorithm in the microscopy image
analysis area and if you use other pixel
classifiers before you've probably um
it's probably running on the random
forest algorithm
and what it's typically used for is the
classification of pixels what we just
saw
or the classification of objects so a
classification of things of cell a
versus cell b for example
and the framework here is um shown on
the left hand side and essentially it's
composed of multiple decision trees that
collectively pull together to give you
an output that selects a class
is this pixel belonging to your one
class or does it belong to your ran
to your background class so that's
really the output of the random force
algorithm
now let's take a further step into this
and ask what's a decision tree
and it's essentially a type of
supervised learning meaning it requires
an expert to help it with the learning
process
and the whole goal of a decision tree is
to make or pull together key features
that really allows us
allows it to make the choice between
what it is that you wanted or
this is the background so again these
key characteristics and these features
are pulled together in one decision tree
to decide this binary choice
so my kind of
non-microscopy
example here is
somebody going in to get a loan and the
loan officer you're working at you're
working with might look at some key
characteristics um to decide whether to
give you this loan or not it could be
your age your education level you
whether or not you've been a homeowner
before your level of income and these
key characteristics or these key
features allows them to make this choice
whether to refuse you the loan or to
give you the loan so we're kind of doing
that
in the same way with the microscopy data
we're trying to create a decision tree
that pulls out the key features that
make up your object of interest
to decide whether this particular pixel
or this particular object is what you
want in versus
what is considered background
so i've said feature a lot what does
this actually look like and what does
this mean in microscopy images
so first of all let's talk about why we
do this and essentially what it does is
it allows us to describe the unique
things and the unique characteristics of
your object or your image
and this allows us to do it in a very
systematic manner and one that pulls out
these these core features and these core
components
so how does this actually happen what
what do we do
um and the process essentially takes
a number of image processing filters and
applies it to your image which
transforms your image and enhance
certain key aspects and certain key
characteristics of the object that
you're trying to detect in the object
that you want
these transform images are then fed into
the um learning process to create the
decision tree to create the random force
that we're looking at
on the left on the right hand side here
i'm showcasing the uh teaching features
that are available in avia we have about
20 plus of them
um we have also kind of organized them
to into
two um categories for you for anybody
who's kind of starting out and don't
really know which features would be best
we've organized them into
good features for standard globular
round shaped objects or for line shaped
objects so you can always start there
within avm
you also might notice here that there's
a kernel size selection so
in this teaching
process
are your images or your objects of a
smaller size of a larger size and things
like that
are
possible to control an aviator and
overall the selection of teaching
features and the kernel size is
something that's typically available
also in other pixel classifier tools
now i
because there are 20 plus sometimes
sometimes even more
of these features i like to kind of
think of them in general categories it
just gives me a good framework to think
about which one may be critical to my
objects and which one i might ex want to
explore a little bit more so the
categories i think about here are zeroth
order derivatives which describes the
original morphology of your image
we have first order derivatives that's
really good at describing edges of
objects
second order derivatives which is good
at describing curvatures and in general
most of the tools available out there
also have a set of what we consider a
specialized feature that goes beyond the
three categories we talked about that
describes other more unique
characteristics such as really thin
lines or something along those those
aspects
so let's take a look at what an example
what a zero order feature would look
like
i've chosen here the gaussian blur for
us to examine and what happens here is
we applied a gaussian blur to the image
at multiple scales so on the right i've
applied it at a scale of a filter size
of 10 and then a filter size of 50.
again these transform images gets fed
into the training process and what it's
really good at doing is describing the
intensity
of your objects of interest at a local
and regional scale so that when you're
looking at for example these um
large nucleus versus a small nucleus at
size filter 10 you have a different
intensity profile than you have at 50
and that might be crucial in
classifying these pixels and
particularly if you wanted to classify a
small nucleus versus a large nucleus
this might be one component that you
might want to to this might be one
feature that you might want to use in
your
in your training here
my second example for you is a first
order feature and this is the difference
of gaussian what happens here is we
apply two gaussian filters with
different sizes
and then we compute the difference
between those two transform images to
get an enough to get another transform
image and this is really good at
describing edges um both on the local
level and again at the regional level
because we're using different sizes here
and you can see from the original versus
the difference in gaussian the edges or
particularly the cell membrane in this
case is really highlighted so this might
be a critical feature for us to use when
we're looking at a pixel classifier that
is trying to amplify or to enhance the
cell membrane and to decrease the
signal from the nucleus in this image
so these are some examples of the types
of features that are available
and
these two are typically used for these
these purposes but again there's a
variety of features that you can explore
to find the best ones that work for what
it is that you're you're trying to
enhance and you're trying to detect
so we've talked about a lot of
components let's kind of pull it back
together and and talk about how does
this all come together and how do you
build this random force um
the random force that's critical for
your pixel classifier training so the
process kind of looks like this so we
take all of the data with the labels
with our examples
we break it up into random subsets of
data
we then teach a decision tree based on
these random subsets and a random
selection of features
so now we have one decision tree
we then repeat this process and because
every time we repeat this process we're
taking a
random subset of the data and a random
subset of the feature each of these
decision trees are slightly
different than one another
and what we're trying to accomplish here
is all of these trees collectively
together make a random forest that it's
going to give us the best classification
of the pixels or the objects into what
we wanted versus the background so you
can see from my description um that's
kind of where the name random force
algorithm comes from right you're
selecting a random subset of things to
create a a series of trees to pull
together um to to make this
classification
all right so let's kind of transition
into maybe a more practical approach or
a more practical way of of looking at
this
so now i kind of want to
so now i want to share with you some of
my best practices when it comes to
training a good pixel classifier
so my first um
best practices for you is to train with
a variety of examples
now why is this important
so the machine learning algorithm to
make an effective one we have to be able
to capture
all of the critical rules all of the
critical aspects of the object that
you're looking for so if you don't have
a variety of ways that your objects can
look like then the pixel classifier in
the
algorithm is unlikely to pull out the
rules that you need
so what kind of things should you
include um again this is not an
exhaustive list this is some that
that might be useful for you um when
you're doing this so first is intensity
distribution so my example with this
fluorescent image here the distribution
we see that was heterogeneous um in the
large nucleus versus the more
homogeneous in the smaller nucleus you
want to be able to capture both of that
variation
we're also capturing here the difference
in sizes so if we only taught on the
large nucleus we might overlook and
might not make the rules necessary to
look for the smaller ones too so you
want to you you want to train and
provide examples on both of these
you might also
think about shapes and different shapes
that your cells and your objects have
and perhaps even other different
characteristics so down here in the
hostology image what i'm trying to
capture here with these arrows is i want
to be able to detect areas with
some dark staining so a lot of staining
in areas that have lighter staining
because to me those are still positive
staining so i want to make sure to
provide examples of both of those
scenarios so that the pixel classifier
can learn that those two scenarios are
what i want and what's important to me
my other best practice is to preview
preview preview during the training
process preview frequently and preview a
lot in the training process
and why is this critical
for me a lot of times the the process of
transforming the images with those
filters makes it difficult for me to
anticipate exactly how the example is
going to affect the final pixel
classifier
it's also important because sometimes i
find that a feature might be really hard
to pull out those rules exactly so the
pixel classifier might need a couple
more examples and it's really hard to
know how many examples um so i like to
preview to see
what
what's missing and what else to provide
so in this video here i'm starting out
with training on just these three kind
of elongated and dark cells and i'm
previewing to see what that looks like
and i find that on my first preview i'm
not getting these round
nucleus here so now i'm going to teach
it on that
this last round i'm finding that while
i'm getting the round nucleus i'm not
getting the ones that are not
super dark and super well stained so now
i'm including that so basically during
this previewing process it gives me an
idea of what's missing what else do i
need to provide to the pixel classifier
to make the best one possible so by
previewing not i'm not
only
seeing
what is being detected but i'm seeing
where things are missing so i can add
just that component it's gonna save you
time and it's to basically
allow you to kind of just look at the
results and not think about this entire
transformation process and how things
will affect the pixel classifier based
on this transformation process
and my best third practice for you is
plan for changes in the future
um i know as scientists we
we typically encounter changes a lot our
experimental conditions change our
imaging parameters change you can
never really plan for everything things
happen
and so i like to kind of in my pixel
classifier training plan for the fact
that things are going to change um so
what happens in avia it's but
particularly is avia allows you to save
what we call the pics training data file
what that includes is a pointer to your
original data and then all the examples
you provided so when you pull this pics
training data out you have these two
critical components to train the pixel
classifier again and it allows you to
add in
more data
more trait and more examples to make the
pixel classifier that you really need so
in my video example here i started out
training on a
image that has a low cell confluency i
apply it to one that has a higher self
fluency and realize this isn't great
it's not picking up what i wanted to so
now i'm gonna actually go in and
add more training add more examples
particularly from that
higher confluency image
so with something like the pix training
data file i can do that and i don't have
to necessarily
plan and have the data up front when i'm
training the original file i always have
the ability to go in and modify it later
so i always tell people whether you
think this is the best pixel classifier
you've created and the one that you're
always going to use it's a good idea um
to basically have this pixel classifier
at this pix training data file just in
case something happened just plan for
things that pla change plan for the
future give yourself a little bit of a
break because sometimes going back and
training it from scratch is difficult
depending on how how long and how
difficult it is to create the pixel
classifier training in the first place
so those are kind of my three best
practices for you
train with a variety of examples
preview constantly when you're changing
when you're training and always have a
plan for the future when things may or
may not when things may change for you
all right with that i would like to
quickly summarize um the presentation
that you've seen today i hope in this
webinar you've seen that machine
learning driven image analysis really
allows you to
leverage your biological knowledge in
providing the examples to the pixel
classifier instead of the rules
and by doing it this way we
have the capacity to add complexity to
the analysis because the pixel
classifier can provide you rules that
you may not have considered or may not
have thought about but this complexity
that you're adding to the analysis
doesn't necessarily have to mean that
you're adding complexity to your work um
the painting of examples make this
fairly straightforward
and a really easy way to
um to basically do the image analysis
i also hope that you've gathered some um
useful tips and a few guidelines to keep
in mind when you're doing um
machine learning pixel classification
training and that the these guidelines
really help you to create a classifier
that's very effective and really useful
for what it is that you're trying to
detect and trying to do in your research
i also want to let you know that avia
does have free trials so if you've been
curious or you want to try out the pixel
classifier or any of the the um examples
i've shown you such as going from a face
contrast image to segmentation that's
available in avian you can give it a try
for free today just go on our website um
av dash software slash demo to request
your own free trial today
and with that i want to say thank you
again very much for attending this
webinar i hope you found it useful um
and now i'll be happy to take questions
that you have regarding the um the
information i presented today i'm also
going to go ahead and invite some of my
colleagues to join me in this q a
session just to provide me with a little
bit support and resource so that we can
make sure that all of your questions are
answered again thank you very much for
attending today and now i'm happy to
take any questions that you have
thank you dr tran for your informative
presentation
we would again like to welcome hoi and
lai as we begin the live q a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
does machine learning require a powerful
computer
um yeah so uh for machine learning you
do not need a very powerful computer to
run the pixel classifier
you essentially what we have implemented
in avia is that it will default to cpu
processing when it does not have when a
gpu power is not available or say let's
say certain features actually do not
have gpu acceleration and that will also
default into using the cpu as well of
course the performance will be a little
bit slower compared to using a gpu but
otherwise you do not need to have a very
powerful machine to use uh the pixel
classifier
thank you
next question
once i've trained a pixel classifier can
i apply it to multiple images
uh yeah so with the pixel classifier you
can apply this uh to multiple different
images what you have actually trained on
with the pixel classifier is not
specifically the information that is uh
uh that is on that image that you uh
that you have but rather the other
information that is encoded so
that allows you to as long as your
experiment or your imaging condition
doesn't change too much you will be able
to apply the pixel classifier to other
images in your experiment and of course
if you uh do once you when you apply the
pixel classifier and you realize that it
uh wasn't performing as well as expected
you can also add those images to your
training data sets so um over time you
can build a much more robust uh
big pixel classifier for your
application
thank you
next question
it is possible to use the ml tools in my
is it possible to use the ml tools in
microscopy images of mammalian fish
amphibian oocytes or eggs
i wonder if development of different
stages could be analyzed and recognized
what kind of image processing tools do
we need to analyze that kind of those
kinds of images
um so i'm so i'm gonna assume that in
this case we're looking at the
development in the early
um in the early development cycle
so in that case yes it is going to be
possible to use the pixel classifier to
analyze uh these images and um the i um
the one thing that we actually i um that
we can also do uh with the pixel
classifier is that um for for instance
um if you were looking at the different
dermal layer organization you just need
to paint kind of the specific regions
that you're interested in and um the
pixel classifier will try to identify
those in for those regions based on the
information that you provided so perhaps
maybe for example maybe in some cases
that
the nuclei are maybe a little bit
smaller or there is a
visible clef in the data on the image so
some of those things could also be
picked up by the pixel classifier as
well
great thank you
next question
how do people document and share their
pixel classification protocols
uh so tip um yes so typically the pixel
classifier um the um the file will be
saved
you will be saved to a specific file and
that you can take that and you can apply
it or to other um you can load it in
another copy of api that your colleague
has or if you um are just trying to
train a piece of classifier you can use
ada community uh which is our version of
the freeway which allows you
to load and train
the full copy of avia to apply
and also like in terms of documentation
sorry
sorry um and then for documentation um
the information about which feature gets
used uh is available and the pixel
classifier as well so when you select uh
when you're training a piece of
classifier you can select which feature
that it will um that you want to apply
uh apply with and that
and and you can have that record as well
great thank you
um next question
hi quinn thanks for the great talk how
does it perform how is the performance
assessed in avia
um thank you very much uh for
for that comment and for the performance
i'm assuming
um
we're talking about the
the
how well
the pixel classifier detects the signal
or the object of interest that you want
and that's really based on your review
of the results so kind of like how we
looked at that video of the preview or
we can also look at the final results
you as kind of the expert is um the
person who will assess how well that
pixel classifier looks and how well it
performs so once it's applied you can
straight away look at what cells are
detected and whether or not that fits
your criteria for a good performance or
not
eight thank you next question
what is the minimum size of labeled data
set
that is good performance
ah yes we get this question asked a lot
and unfortunately it's not one i can
give you um a blind answer on basically
it varies quite a bit by what it is that
you're trying to enhance or you're
trying to segment
um as we saw in the example of the
training process it can be you know just
a small region of interest
i have done this
with just an example of a few cells um
and i've done this where we've had to do
um a couple of previews and um
and
you know 10
maybe 15 examples and things like that
so it varies quite a bit but that's one
of the reasons why that preview
functionality is immensely helpful
because you can
look at it along the way
and see how well it's performing and add
just enough of what is needed to get a
good pixel classifier
so again it really varies depending on
what kind of image analysis you're
looking for and
the um images that you're kind of
starting out with
all right great
um next question
how well does avia play with other image
analysis programs such as fiji and file
formats
so um i'll take the file format first so
for file formats avia can read a number
of file formats i can't remember the
exact
amount of the top of my head but at
least 15 kind of
file formats natively so that's just us
reading um directly
for
file formats that we don't cover we do
have a bridge with bio format um a uh
a script or or kind of an application in
fiji that covers i think they're up to
like 400
500 file formats now so there is that
bridge if we don't cover the file
formats that you need
um in terms of kind of um how well it
works with other programs so av is
optimized for tip
which other programs such as fiji and in
general
other image now let's analysis program
will work with so you can
basically save and import your export
your data into kind of a tiff format and
use other programs
down the line if that's what you want to
great thank you
and we'll wrap up with that last
question thank you again dr tran and
hoyan for your time today and your
important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor leica microsystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you